hätte ich das gesicht ich habe über
monat zu überlegt welche video ich als
nächstes das lag daran dass ich dieses
video mir überlegt habe denn heute
werden wir ein gesamtes outfit mit dem
schwärzesten schwarz der welt ein
verbrechen an den superbullen video wird
das westliche welt ja das war mal das
schwert ist mit schwarz der welt zeigt
euch das mal kurz ist sieht schon echt
echt heftig aus oder was man mit ihrem
aber der künstler der hinter diesem
schwach steht hat das schwarzen noch mal
verbessert und ich habe nicht eine die
zwei sondern drei flaschen vom
schwärzesten schwarzen der welt gekauft
und mein gesamtes outfit schwarz angst
meinen hier ist das paket
wir eröffnen das ganze ganz normal ich
glaube genauso lassen und letzte mal
auch verpacken dass jetzt halt drauf
steht weist das dritte ist haben wir das
mal aus ich hab mir schon vorkehrungen
getroffen dass ich meine vision insel
nicht an maler elektriker und hier ist
das black keys to throw wird sagen wir
machen wir einen kleinen vergleich auf
alufolie weil es hat nicht viel zur
beiden jetzt einfach mal anzuschauen
ein wenig alufolie seht ihr das das sind
800.000 judt so ein bisschen davon und
jetzt droht denkt man wird so überhaupt
keinen unterschied erkennen ja so sieht
wirklich genau gleich aus das geht das
hier war zu voll wird das hier ist toll
so wäre das hier trocken natürlich sagen
meinte normalzustand bayern tun das
naheliegende könnte es schon reichen
ich sollte so das fordert jetzt auch
langweilig hier
oder alles treten sollte man das
interessante frau wir wollen das hier
sieht nix leute haben die tischtennis
war jetzt an gemeint ist das erste was
getrocknet ist und guckt euch das hier
einfach mal an mit ihr das das ist
einfach so als will ich nicht schwarzes
loch in meiner hand halten man könnte
jetzt theoretisch einfach einen film dem
jeweiligen datum dafür funktionieren
dann könnt ihr noch ausmachen und den
beiden stecken
auch das würde funktionieren aber
erstmals sind dabei sehr schwarz ist
schon megacool also leute ja schonmal
mittel dafür gemacht dass er bin ich
jetzt von dem einfachen defekt nicht so
krass geflasht aber mir das ganze gleich
mit einem kompletten outfit machen
kraft wir sind noch nicht so weit drüber
wird zum vergleich aber ich habe es
nicht so dünn aufgetragen bekommen mit
youtube deshalb macht es keinen großen
unterschied ich mache das erste ist ein
komplett weißen sweater hier raus geholt
gucken wir einfach mal anhand einer
kleinen stelle ob das funktionieren kann
machen ein bisschen was drauf und guck
mal wie das ganze text ob es heftig oder
das heftigste und elan leute hast du s 3
fahren könnte dort vielleicht ein
bisschen wenig werden oder das schon
heftig ins akteurs unterschied zu deinem
t shirt dieses reiche hinter der kamera
ist der in jeder weise dave auch einen
tollen kanal sagt ich war die ganze zeit
passiert was mit dem schwärzesten
schwarz machen soll wird er macht ja so
ein schuh passen
ich wollte jetzt auch dann belagert ihn
in seinen kommentaren und schreibt ist
ihm das tun das ist kürzer auf euch wenn
ihr es tut
gesetzlich nicht das beste quartal
gegeben dass zustimmen wird
ich musste day finden das mir ein
bisschen hilft ganz ehrlich das ist
jetzt vielleicht die ersten züge leerer
von beckwith das heißt es könnte schwer
werden auch die rose zu machen wir
versuchen natürlich trotzdem
wir geben ja alles was recht bei team
krankhafter wir können definitiv nur
eine seite von pohlig am ball war
diese drei dosen farbe haben 70 euro
gekostet also super das safety checklist
geht schon leer jetzt die erste kurve
habe ich mich wenigstens setzen wenn ich
schon nicht bezahlt werde
ja tatsächlich den ersten sitz
reingeschnitten leid ich bin davon
ausgegangen dass wir den ersten schritte
das ist ein bisschen grau bestreitet das
war das jetzt angebrochen kein super
aber ich sag es trotzdem
die jacobs nase sowie jakob nase knappen
vermeint jetzt gerade ich habe
eigentlich im café betreibt man kann
nicht alles am himmel blickt die ja es
ist halt so
inhalt deutlich größer inzwischen redet
nicht gepresst 1180 was derzeit erzählte
gestern habe ich etwas abgebremst dabei
[Musik]
und heute die letzten finishing touches
beim später für zweieinhalb wochen
verbraucht und ich werde das ganze ist
mal auf hängt da muss ich irgendwie
schaffen das
was nichts anderes berührt weil ich noch
dieses schwarze karotte geht arena
bisher nicht durchgeführt und jetzt
glaub das wird richtig kraft das wird
selten richtig richtig kraft nicht
wundern das ist jetzt noch nicht
komplett spaß weil es erst mal komplett
trocken
doch jetzt machen wir doch die hose die
muss natürlich kommt das schwarz anmalen
weil sie miniatur lauf hat den schritt
dann gibt's keine andere alternative als
die komplett schwarz anzumalen
wir beschleunigen das ganze jetzt mal
ich würde sagen einfach so ich glaube
jetzt einfach wahrscheinlich bei dem
anderen auch schon die ganze zeit der
fcb heute ist mir leid die kirche welt
gerade wieder euro würde ich meine hand
sein bis dahin bleibt er mit fahrerlosen
und wenn ihr euch immer mal gefragt
haben wie man einen schwarz angemalte
rose am besten trocken trick befreit
der fortschritt von hier drüben kommt
sogar darauf
das war - und viele von uns haben sich
bestimmt auch gefragt wie man einen
pulli cognis
viren später kennen können habe ich das
aus mit jetzt anders komplett schwarze
schwärzester outfits der welt brauche
nicht hier gedreht wird nicht passieren
zudem ist seid ihr bereit für das
schwert ist darauf mit der welt ich
schon
diese kosten sind diese phase zu laufen
erklärt werden bei den palmen sieht man
ein bisschen aber ansonsten ist schon
wichtig um die sache ist die farbe zeit
verstärkt worden und wird ihr das bild
der pulli jede delle und sonst was
bleibt einfach drin aber ich finde es
erstmals übel kraft wie das des siegers
also das hier ist die auch wenn ich
wirklich sagen macht es nicht zu hause
sind namenlosen ein bisschen rund nötig
also man kann es zwar nicht im alltag
anziehen weil man komplett eingeschränkt
weil bewegung bringt jetzt ins andere
kopf bleiben will
es ist nicht so ganz einfach aber
trotzdem ich sehe jetzt schon so eine
abstufung das ist nicht ganz perfekt
schwarz ist und so drei flaschen
blackberry kunden haben wir verbraucht
die sind jetzt kandidiert drin soll ich
doch schon welche anderen sachen anmalen
ich gesagt habe wenn ja was für mich und
lass gerne leicht durch ein aufwendiges
videos hatte beim mega spaß gemacht wie
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder ein
paar monaten wieder ein neues video von
mir mathis